hey guys Anna and Dave we are kicking
back and I saw this story that I thought
was kind of interesting do you know that
Google wants to put ads literally
everywhere every part of your life if
google has their way is going to have an
ad involved in it in a letter that they
sent to the sfcc this is just incredible
they are saying that they hope to put
ads on quote refrigerators car
dashboards thermostats glasses and
watches to name just a few possibilities
this has something to do with them
buying nest nest makes these like fancy
home thermostats and literally all these
products that we have in our homes
thermostats your car all of this stuff
is going to have ads on it even though
you paid for it you know like it so I
find it fascinating because you know
with our phones you see ads on stuff oh
yeah you see ads if you you know you're
searching on the web or you get an app
you see all the s but now then they're
in a sigh are still going to be
connected somehow so that they'll after
you've made the purchase yeah they're
still be able to put ads on it and then
then it brings up all the stuff about
them watching you all the time and they
know how hot your houses and then you
jump in your car they know what bridge
you went over and then you're walking
out of your phone so they have you
geo-located and all of that stuff but
it's like this is just kind of the
future right no I mean I feel like this
is the kind of thing that consumers can
fight back against I don't want ads on
my thermostat or ads on whatever your
refrigerator and ya know that sounds
ridiculous I mean I think about how ugly
the product can be here's the reality I
get it Google wants to advertise as much
as possible that's how we are able to
use their service their search engine
for free advertisement makes all the
sense in the world but there's bounds of
reason right as jake would say like you
don't want to have ads on your
refrigerator or your car I mean we want
our products to be aesthetically
pleasing and if they're not we're not
going to buy them so I think that they
have to tread carefully with this I
don't know exactly how they plan on
doing it but you got to make the product
nice to look at and no one's gonna want
ads on every single object in their home
don't you think though it's gonna be one
of those things where it's gonna happen
so slowly that we're just going to
slowly accept it like everything else
you know you mean like with all this
technology just more intrusive
keeps coming and it's like how do you
fight it you know what you mean so like
your friends are going to have you know
smart cars or whatever it is and they're
going to be doing it and then you're
gonna be like I want a smart car because
you know I or whatever whatever these
yeah I'm more concerned about the
privacy issue right so you know what
what about all these new appliances and
like gaming consoles and things like all
these things that were buying um Xbox is
watching you yeah have cameras I worry
about the camera on my laptop all the
time I worry about the camera on my iPad
all the time and so I remember there was
this one mainstream journalists who
thought it was crazy that michael
hastings wanted to cover his his webcam
and by the way michael hastings you know
legendary reporter died in a really
tragic car accident a year ago in june
um so I I don't know like I it might be
a state of paranoia but i think that is
legitimate considering the fact that so
many companies want to know so much
about your personal life so they can
sell it to third parties so they can you
know get advertisers to do targeted ads
the NSA is spying on us like the privacy
issue is what concerns me though yeah
for me it's like half privacy just what
you're entitled to in your own home that
we shouldn't be subjected to advertising
everywhere that and then of course it's
the abuse of it too it's all that stuff
and who's watching us on the web cams at
all I hope nobody's watching this right
now
you